[Music]
today we understand the basics of angle
measurement which we need for
understanding trigonometry in detail we
are familiar with the term angle angle
is a measure of the rotation of a given
ray about its initial point what does
this mean
let's draw a ray or a o is the initial
point of Ray Oh a we rotate array or a
to this position let's call this new
position of the array or a as Oh a - the
initial position of Ray or a is called
the initial side and the final position
of Ray Oh a - is called the terminal
side so Oh a is the initial side and Oh
a - is the terminal side we can also
call this initial point as the vertex
there is an angle subtended between the
two rays notice that we rotated ray o a
in the counterclockwise direction to get
ray or a - we can also rotate ray o a in
the clockwise direction to get the
terminal side as o a double - like this
so the initial side is Oh a and the
terminal side is Oh a double - when we
go counter clockwise from the initial
side to the terminal side the angle
measurement is positive and when we go
clockwise the angle measurement is
negative so here the angle subtended is
positive and here it's negative now
let's understand what is the unit of
measure for angles we will be studying
three units of measurement in this video
along with their symbols the most common
unit of measure is degrees one degree is
represented as follows
this symbol is a small raised circle
let's understand how to measure the
angle of rotation we know that one full
rotation of the initial side is 360
degrees do you notice something
interesting
yes the initial site coincides with the
terminal side it's hard to differentiate
which way is a a and which way is a
triple - look at this highlighted part
we can also say that 360 degrees is one
full rotation
now if 360 degrees is one full rotation
then what is one degree yes one degree
is one three sixtieth of a full rotation
but wait this degree the smallest unit
of measure for angles well no there are
smaller units of measure they are called
minute and second one minute is
represented as follows look at this
symbol it's called prime so one minute
is written as one prime and one second
is written as follows this symbol is
called double prime similarly one second
is written as one double prime so we are
now familiar with the symbols for degree
minute and second but watch
relationships do their share
well one degree is made up of sixty
minutes and one minute is made up of 60
seconds having understood this can you
tell me the relationship between degree
and second that's right one degree is
equal to 3600 seconds why do we need
these smaller units with smaller units
of measurements like minute and second
we can express an angle more accurately
so an angle theta measuring 50 degrees
25 minutes and 10 seconds would be
written as follows and this is
definitely more accurate than just 50
degrees we are familiar with a common
tool to measure angles in terms of
degrees I'm sure you have it in your
geometry box well that's right I'm
talking about the protractor and we use
it to measure angles in the geometry
class but how do we measure minutes and
seconds
as a matter of fact there are specially
designed measuring devices to measure
angles of objects that are too small to
be measured by regular inspection such
tools are used commonly in the
manufacturing industry well this
discussion helped us understand angle
measurement in terms of degrees minutes
and seconds but can angles also be
expressed in terms of other units of
measurement let's find that out in our
next video
[Music]